the people who lived in the house that
once stood here
piled up and tied down everything they
could
a final act of desperation
but also hope
of returning one day
residents of dara layar say the water is
likely to recede in two months
but across balochistan people are
wondering if they can last that long
after his house was washed away golamali
moved his family into an unfinished shop
it may be better than a roadside tent
but not much
wherever you go ask anyone nobody has
received anything they're pushing
beating and hurting poor people the aid
is coming for people like us in need but
so far we haven't received anything
everyone we speak to says the same thing
local government officials politicians
and feudal lords are hoarding relief
goods
the landlords aren't giving us anything
we've been worried for weeks we wait at
the district commissioner's office all
night they give truckloads to the
landlords but nothing is made available
to us the police beat us and tell us go
away there's nothing for you here
everything is run according to the
landlords nothing is happening for us
international aid has arrived but
inequality persists even in crisis
many want the army to step in
we appeal to the world don't give funds
to this government and these feudal
lords put it in the hands of the
pakistani army they can deliver it to us
the feudal lords here to whom we have
given our votes have given us nothing
pakistan's army chief was in balochistan
on tuesday general kamar bajwa's second
visit in as many weeks
the largest province with the smallest
population means people in trouble are
in pockets spread across vast areas
and getting them help takes longer
a truck filled with tents was unloaded
at the district commissioner's office in
the morning
by nightfall a crowd had gathered hoping
for anything they could get their hands
on
people tell us they've been turned away
over and over again for days
al jazeera's repeated requests for an
interview with the district commissioner
were unsuccessful
people here say the living don't have
enough food shelter or clean water
but even the dead aren't spared
the indignities of this crisis
zain basravi al-jazeera dara layar
balochistan province pakistan